there's a phrase that lots of the most
extreme and radical religious right
republicans will pull out for special
occasions when they really want to go
off the deep end and that phrase is
the mark of the beast and republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene is
pulling that phrase out
as a reference to vaccine passports now
a little background first on mark of the
beast
mark of the beast is a symbol in the
book of revelation
in the bible it has four or
five different interpretations depending
on
which sect of christianity you are part
of
let's look at the clip first and i'll
explain
the way that marjorie taylor green is
using the phrase mark of the beast here
okay let's take a look
they want you to be required to have
something called a coveted
passport and this this would mandate
your ability to be able to travel your
ability to be able to go to events
your ability to be able to buy and sell
and i asked the question earlier today
is this something like biden's mark of
the beast because that is really
disturbing
and um not good oh if you're gonna come
into the football game or the baseball
game or the concert
you need your vaccine passport because
we're trying to do a good job to keep
everyone safe
this is what the biden administration is
trying to talk to these private
companies
into doing well let's analyze that you
see
it's still the same thing it's still
fascism
or communism whatever you want to call
it but it's in
it's coming from private companies so i
have a term for that i call it corporate
communism
i love that at the end it's fascism or
communism
whatever you want to call it even if
those are two completely different
things
call it whatever whatever it is whatever
you want to call it that's what we're
against
now the relevant definition here for
mark of the beast
is from some fundamentalist christian
groups who interpret the mark of the
beast as a requirement for
commerce to mean that the mark might be
an
object with the function of like a
credit card
or an id an rfid microchip
implant like a decade ago on the show i
interviewed some fundamental right-wing
christian who said that
rfid chipping that's starting to appear
in different consumer products
is the mark of the beast that's the the
the sort of umbrella the universe of
interpretation of mark of the beast that
she's using
some of these groups believe that the
implantation
of chips may be the imprinting of the
mark of the beast
and this would be a prophecied
requirement for trade as a precursor to
god's wrath
so yeah anyway in this case the vaccine
passport
is that mark of the beast that
a requirement for commerce of sorts
i don't want to dig too far into the
other religious interpretations of mark
of the beast because each of them
applies only to like a small
percentage of christians and christians
are just a portion of americans and
americans are just a portion of all
world citizens
who believe this mark of the beast stuff
i want to focus on the silliness
of focusing in on the vaccine passport
as some evil thing
when it comes to covet vaccines
and there's a lot of people who have
been tweeting about this
and they seem ignorant to the fact that
they even participate in and i'll give
you examples donald trump jr has been
tweeting similarly
about vaccine passports not religiously
based he tweeted for example
quote don't let them turn america into
china
vaccine passports are a serious threat
to american
civil liberties another example from don
jr who tweeted
vaccine passports communist china would
be proud of the democrats recent push
his kids and most kids go to schools
that require vaccines it's just not been
the covet vaccine
for now although we are already seeing
colleges who are saying
you need a coveted vaccine to come back
to campus those
same colleges have had other vaccine
requirements for a long time
when i went to summer camp i needed
proof of certain vaccinations
when i went to college i needed to go
and get a physical
and i needed to get certain vaccines and
have proof that i had those vaccines
this is not new this is not
controversial
it's no more controversial when it's
this vaccine
instead of others some people will say
david this is like requiring a flu shot
it's really not in the sense that the
covid
death rate unvaccinated is way higher
than the flu death rate unvaccinated so
to make it i don't know why we would be
talking about that vaccines
are required already to do all sorts of
different things
including going presumably to the
schools that don junior's kids go to
maybe he doesn't know maybe he's not
involved in their schooling i have no
idea
but the idea that this is somehow
different because covet is newer is very
very silly
uh they won't stop with this stuff
they're focused in on cancel culture
they're focused in on uh um debt and
deficit because biden wants to do
infrastructure and all these different
things
and they're focused in on vaccine
passports right now
just don't fall for it don't fall for it
there's nothing controversial about it
whatsoever
i would imagine what 90 90 95 99
of the people talking about vaccine
passports have
either themselves or kids uh
that we had required vaccinations which
they got
period wasn't controversial they're not
even talking about it maybe they're not
even aware of it